bonjour tedx suis vraiment très content
d'être là bonjour la voix je sais pas si
on dit comme ça la voix ou la voix off
j'aimerais avoir la même voie parce que
quand je travaille avec les enfants je
suis sûr que ça aurait un effet apaisant
j'ai un côté un peu voix terminator qui
des fois on pousse un peu bon je voulais
dit je suis psychologue je travaille
avec des enfants principalement un peu
avec des adultes mais avec les enfants
une grande partie de mon travail de mon
travail pardon consiste à jouer avec un
enfant qui qui ne joue pas est un enfant
qui est malade qui ne va pas bien et
comme vous êtes tous de vieux enfants
si vous n'avez pas joué au moins cette
semaine ou moins une fois et bien
probablement vous êtes en train de
préparer la réflexion de la cuisine d'un
de mes collègues donc essayer de jouer
c'est toujours important alors le jeu il
ya un retour avec leur sait très bien le
jeu pourquoi c'est pourquoi c'est
important parce que ça ça ça permet de
d'établir des contacts de nourrir
l'imaginaire etc etc
il ya un jeu que vous devez connaître
qui a été affichée ici c'est le jeu de
ricochets prenez un caillou sur une
plage et puis vous le jeter dans l'eau
et puis ça fait des ricochets vous
comptez 1 2 3 4 5 et c'est le ricochet
c'est un jeu qui est tout à fait banale
mais comme tous les jeux il est très
important parce que jouer avec une
pierre et puis un plan d'eau c'était
autre chose avec la même chose c'est se
montrer créateurs quand on joue aux
ricochets qu'est ce que l'on fait on
lutte contre les pesanteurs contre la
pesanteur et on lutte aussi contre les
pesanteurs les choses qui nous amène et
qui nous attire vers le fond on va
essayer de jouer ensemble on va lancer
un caillou on va faire deux trois
ricochet je fais semblant ne pas savoir
mais en fait je sais parfaitement il y
en aura trois il pourrait y en avoir
beaucoup plus mais on va s'arrêter à
trois premiers ricochet les premiers
ricochet ça commence à connaissent
burger première moitié du 19e siècle
j'ai un côté un peu docteur ou alors je
suis capable de ne voyager dans le temps
donc à koning berck qu'est ce qui se
passe il ya cette pompe sur cette bonne
ville est un des jeux des habitants de
la ville et de demander à leurs enfants
s'il est possible de faire une promenade
qui passerait par tous les ponts et
revenir sur le point de départ les
enfants se casse beaucoup la tête et il
n'arrive bien entendu pas à trouver la
réponse parce que les adultes sont
souvent facétieux avec les avec les
enfants et un jour bien évidemment il ya
un enfant qui arrive il s'appelle eu
l'air il est mathématicien et il trouve
la réponse
alors je vous laisse chercher là la
réponse vous la trouverez assez
facilement avec monsieur google ou votre
moteur de recherche favori ou simplement
vous cassant un peu la tête
mais ce qui est important aujourd'hui
c'est que l'air va fonder une nouvelle
discipline deux disciplines importante
pour le propos d'aujourd'hui alors la
première ce que il
il crée une nouvelle forme de jeux
mathématiques les mathématiciens sont de
grands enfants
ils adorent jouer on comprend pas
toujours leur jeu sauf si on est
soi-même mathématicien et il
il lance la mode d d d énigmes
mathématiques de ce type là la seconde
chose qui est importante c'est que il va
fonder mathématiquement ce que l'on va
appeler des années plus tard l'analyse
des réseaux sociaux
la théorie des graphes on va faire un
saut on était à la première moitié du
xixème et on va arriver en 1947 avec un
monsieur qui s'appelle iacob moreno
c'est un monsieur qui est un peu
fantasque un peu un peu bizarre il fonde
une nouvelle technique thérapeutique on
appelle le psychodrame
et quand ils rencontrent freud il lui
dit moi je commence là où vous vous
arrêtez vous occupez de psychologie
individuelle moi je m'occupe de groupe
alors il a comme idée de donner une
représentation graphique des relations
sociales il travaille dans un pensionnat
de jeunes filles c'est pas des jeunes
filles de bonne famille sont des jeunes
filles qui ont été placés par les par
les juges et il leur demande de noter
sur un bout de papier avec qui elle
aimerait être dans quel pavillon elle
aimerait être est il note que on obtient
des représentations graphiques très
particulière il ya des personnes qui
sont des stars sont les personnes qui
sont toujours cités par toutes les
autres et puis à les isoler il ya les
parias il ya celle qu'on qu'on laisse de
côté et son idée est que
avec cette représentation graphique on
peut avoir une représentation assez
précise de la cohésion de l'ensemble est
plus l'ensemble et cohésif mieux c'est
pour tout le monde et il note que cette
représentation graphique permet même de
suivre des projets sociaux parce que
dans cet établissement quand une dizaine
de jeunes filles fugue
c'est une dizaine de jeunes filles qui
sont dans le même club stearns n'utilise
pas ce mot là mais c'est l'idée
dans le même groupe de personnes toutes
celles qui s'était choisi entre elle
fugue en même temps des années plus tard
on est en 47 on va aller dans les années
60 puis de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
le voyez le ricochet ça peut nous porter
loin donc on arrive du côté de la varde
avec un monsieur que vous devez
connaître qui s'appelle stanley milgram
c'est un sociologue du coup je me trompe
un psychologue et ce psychologue vous
veut savoir comment et où et comment la
société américaine et cohésive est ce
que les gens sont liés les uns aux
autres et comment est-ce qu'ils sont
liés alors pour cela il prend deux
villes qui sont très éloignées l'une de
l'autre mais sociologiquement c'est
wichita dans le kansas et puis omaha
dans le kentucky
alors ce sont des soucis des sociétés
des villes qui sont très différentes
sociologiquement et dans l'idée de
milgram il ya peu de chances que des
personnes de wichita connaissent des
personnes de omaha alors même qu'il y a
que quatre cents kilomètres à faire 400
km en 1964 dans votre magnifique ford
mustang vous les faites en même pas 6
heures mais alors il invente un
dispositif expérimental il donne aux
habitants de wichita et une enveloppe en
leur demandant de la poster de l'envoyer
à une personne qui se trouve à dans
l'état à côté et la consigne et que s'il
ne la connaissent pas directement il
faut poster la lettre à une personne
dont ils pensent qu'elle pourrait la
connaît tous qu'elle pourrait connaître
quelqu'un qui connaît etc etc et ils
récupèrent les résultats il ya une
lettre qui arrivent à destination aux
deux bons alors milgram est tout à fait
stupéfait il y en a une autre qui arrive
en dise est bon il semble assez
extraordinaire mais quand même en
moyenne les lettres m 5,5 bons pour
arriver à destination
est ce de là que vient l'expression six
degrés de séparation
n'a pas été inventé par milgram un
misérable c'est vraiment un psychologue
c'est un gars sérieux il fait il fait de
la science et la les six degrés de
séparation était inventée par un metteur
en scène qui a écrit une pièce de
théâtre alors 5 5 ou 6 degrés de
séparation c'est vraiment court ça veut
dire que dans aux états unis puis par
extension dans le monde entier
et bien tout le monde se connaît plus ou
moins et que l'on peut en voyageant de
liens en liens d'amis en ami de
connaissances aux connaissances
finalement faire le tour du monde
assez assez rapidement alors qu'est ce
que ça nous apprend ça nous apprend déjà
des choses que l'on savait déjà mais
c'est toujours intéressant de les voir
sous un autre angle
c'est comme ça qu'on fait de la science
on apprend les choses d'une façon puis
d'une autre
donc ça nous apprend ça nous permet de
revisiter une vieille notion qu'on
appelle en psychologie l'homophilie
l'homophilie c'est quoi c'est à dire que
les personnes qui se ressemble
s'assemble
c'est pour ça que les hipsters vont
toujours par deux ou trois et que les
barbus sont toujours ensemble et que les
rastas avons par bandes etc etc
bon donc ça c'est une notion qui est
bien connue qui s'assemble se ressemble
c'est une notion qui est vraiment
importante puisque elle s'enracine
profondément dans notre toute toute
petite enfance quand je dis petite
enfance je vous parle des premières
semaines de vie
les psychologues du développement ont
montré que dans les premières
interactions du bébé avec sa mère parce
que généralement c'est la mère qui fait
quand même le job
même s'il ya des papas paraît-il qui
sont aussi compétents que des mamans ce
qui peut arriver
ma foi on va utiliser le terme générique
mer même si la mère peut être un hipster
alors on va garder ça donc les
psychologues du développement ont montré
que lorsque un adulte s'occupe d'un
enfant il ya toute une danse mime le
mimos gestuelle est effective qui fait
que les états affectifs de l'ain
s'accordent avec les états affectifs de
l'autre et c'est comme ça que petit à
petit l'enfant intègre de façon très
profonde et très inconsciente aussi des
éléments affectifs et puis relationnel
des histoires etc etc
du coup dès que je parle des bd je me
perds donc là je oui alors donc quoi
est-ce que j'en étais l'ailé donc c'est
une honte une vieille notion c'est que
c'est quelque chose qui est connu c'est
quelque chose qui s'enracine
profondément dans l'histoire de chacun
et c'est quelque chose qui est même
enracinée dans notre biologie puisque on
a chacun dans notre cerveau des neurones
miroirs c'est à dire des nerfs des
neurones qui se déclenche
non pas lorsque nous faisons quelque
chose mais lorsque nous regardons
quelqu'un comme nous faire quelque chose
vous regarder quelqu'un jouer au tennis
et bien vous avez les neurones moteurs
qui permettent le mouvement du coup
droit qui s'activent ça marche aussi
pour le kyodo donc il ya même pas besoin
de ceux de s'entraîner alors les
l'homophilie donc c'est quelque chose
qui est qui est tout à fait que l'on
peut que l'on que l'on retrouve la
seconde chose qui est importante c'est
que la la la les éléments sur lesquels
les comportements se construisent sont
beaucoup plus sociaux qu'on ne le
pensait au départ en penser que
finalement on était influencé juste par
nos amis 1
on est tous dans la même salle
normalement vie à peu près tous les
mêmes émotions on a à peu près tous les
mêmes pensées surtout si vous êtes
largement captivé par les choses
magnifiques que je suis en train de vous
dire mais ça va un peu plus loin
ça va un peu plus loin parce que on est
aussi influencée par non seulement nos
amis nos proches nos familles nos
parents mais les amis de nos amis on a
pu montrer par exemple des choses aussi
étonnant que le suicide
quand on quand on y pense on y pense
généralement comme quelque chose qui est
un acte intime c'est que chacun a sa vie
sa trajectoire et certains choisissent
celle là plutôt plutôt qu'une autre
mais en fait on a pu montrer que le
suicide était aussi déterminée par des
lois sociales
c'est quelque chose qui est pour une
part ancien puisque déjà dürckheim a
écrit un gros livre sur le suicide donc
il a montré les composantes sociales du
suicide
mais avec les techniques qui nous
viennent de l'analyse des eaux d
j'allais dire des réseaux sociaux avec
les techniques qui nous viennent les
connaissances qui nous viennent de la
théorie des graphes et bien on a
constaté que c'était ça aller beaucoup
plus loin que cela on a pu constater que
un adolescent ou une jeune personne
était plus à risque de commettre un
suicide lorsque un proche de sa famille
ou de son réseau d'amitiés avait fait un
suicide mais ça marchait aussi lorsqu'un
ami de ses amis avaient fait un suicide
donc ça veut dire qu'on n'est non
seulement influencé par nos proches mais
on est influencé par nos lointains par
les amis de nos amis par les amis des
amis de nos amis on a pu montrer aussi
que ce n'est pas simplement une question
d'influencé de lien c'est une question
aussi de structures du réseau
lorsque vous êtes dans un réseau social
qui fragmentent et lorsque vous êtes un
peu isolé dans votre réseau social vous
avez plus de chance de commettre un
suicide chance aux thermes probabilité
un collant s'entendent bien
lorsque vous êtes dans un réseau social
où les gens ne se connaissent pas par
exemple vous connaissez la personne à et
vous connaissez la personne b né à ne
connais pas b&b bien les probabilités de
commettre un suicide sont aussi plus
grande
donc vous voyez que non seulement on est
des êtres sociaux ont construit des
réseaux sociaux comme on dit maintenant
des relations sociales
mais ses relations sociales nous
construisent aussi de façon tout est
tout aussi tout ceci importante elle
nous façonnent de deux de la tête aux
pieds
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'il
faut garder en tête on n'est pas
simplement ce que l'on est en fonction
du 2
de notre histoire de la façon dont cela
représente de la façon dont on
transforme les choses on est aussi très
largement transformé par des choses qui
nous viennent de notre horizon
lorsque l'on a pu montrer c'est que non
seulement le monde
on était dans des groupes qui étaient
régis par la loi des six degrés de
séparation ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'important je suis assis pas ou à
six personnes d'une poignée de main avec
barack obama ou avec nicolas sarkozy ou
avec le dr roux qui c'est et ça c'est
une chose qui est importante mais une
autre chose qui peut être encore plus
importante c'est que nous sommes à trois
degrés d' influence 3° d'influents ça
veut dire que je suis influencé moi par
mes proches les amis de mes amis et les
amis des amis de mes amis ça marche pour
moi et ça marche très probablement aussi
pour vous alors on s'est posé la
question de savoir mais pourquoi 3°
pourquoi pas 4 5 ou 6 alors les idées
qui ont que l'on a eu
nous la communauté des chercheurs ou
plutôt le chercheur qui a proposé cette
ses premières hypothèses est que
finalement ces trois degrés sont un
héritage de l'histoire de l'humanité
très probablement au début de l'humanité
dans les premiers groupes sociaux
l'humanité n'allait pas bien plus loin
que trois degrés de séparation dont ils
n'avaient pas besoin de d'être
influencée par des personnes qui sont au
delà des amis des amis de mes amis ça
n'avait aucun sens et comme maintenant
au moins on vit dans un monde qui est
beaucoup plus grand que et que le monde
de l'uci et bien on pourrait être
influencée par des personnes qui sont au
delà de ces trois degrés mais il ya le
poids de l'héritage qui qui est là la
seconde raison c'est que finalement le
signal se perd dans le réseau lorsque je
suis influencé par quelque chose ou par
quelqu'un que ce soit émotionnel ou où
que ce soit une idée c'est toujours un
signal qui se transmet de proche en
proche et il est probable que le signal
au bout de trois itérations soit
dégradée pensez par exemple au téléphone
arabe
on m'a dit qu'on m'a dit qu'on m'a dit
au bout d'un moment on arrive à une
histoire total font tout à fait
différente et le réseau transmet
une nouvelle histoire différente de la
première et enfin la troisième raison
qui expliquerait le fait que finalement
on est con ne soient pas influencés a
plus de droit 3 degrés de séparation
tient à la structure même du réseau qui
fait qui ferait que l'information en
arriverait à se perdre
donc au final qu'est ce qu'on a à partir
de ce jeu d'enfant ou ont jeté des
cailloux dans une sur un plan d'eau on à
la prise de conscience qui me semble de
plus en plus nécessaire que les choses
sont liées on vit finalement dans un
petit monde un très très petit monde
vous imaginez on est quand même quelques
milliards quelques milliards séparés par
trois degrés de séparation c'est
vraiment pas beaucoup ça c'est déjà une
première chose et c'est quelque chose
d'autant plus important si l'on prend en
compte le fait que non seulement il n'y
a pas trop six degrés de séparation mais
il y a 3 degré d' influence essayer de
compter ça veut dire que si moi j'ai dix
amis et que tous mes amis ont dix amis
c'est à dire que je suis influencé par
plusieurs milliers de personnes dont je
n'ai absolument pas conscience et ça
c'est vraiment je crois la chose qu'il
faut que l'ong que l'on garde tous en
tête ce que nous sommes intimement ce
que nous sommes dans le secret de nos de
nos pensées de nos for intérieur nous le
sommes aussi parce que nous le devons à
plus d'un autre nous sommes constitués
construit
je cherche à faire chameau qui soit
suffisamment fort façonné par des
influences dont certaines sont des
influences de nos cercles familiaux et
de noeuds du cercle de nos intimes dont
nous pouvons en avoir conscience
mais surtout et encore par des
influences que qui ne sont étrangères
encore que pas tellement étrangères
parce que même à 3° d' influence même à
six degrés de séparation
eh bien nous sommes toujours influencé
par d'autres êtres humains donc c'est le
moment de conclure j'aurais envie de
vous dire que il faut vraiment prendre
conscience de cela et peut-être que on
peut en prendre d'autant plus conscience
si on utilise une formule que moi j'aime
bien mais aussi je laime bien parce que
c'est moi qui les ai inventées
donc moi je vais vous la donner la
formule c'est la suivante c'est que
finalement la vie est un long fleuve de
ric hochet je vous remercie